There are major shortcomings with
the electronic code-book method.
First, we observe that for the same key,
if two plain-text blocks are the same,
then their corresponding server
text blocks are also the same.
This is true if the two plain-text
blocks are in the same message, or
across two different messages.
As long as they use the same key.
This is a major weakness that can
be exploited by cryptoanalysis.
For example, if it is known that the
message always starts out with certain
predefined fields, then cryptoanalysis
can have a number of known plain-text,
server-text pairs to work with.
As another example,
if the message has repetitive elements,
then these elements can be identified
by cryptoanalysis as well.
In other words, whenever we see
two identical cipher-text bocks,
we know that the corresponding
plain-text blocks are exactly the same.
And if we have obtained the plain-text
block off a cipher-text block,
then if you see the same
cipher-text block again,
we know the corresponding
plain-text block already.
In other words, ECB does not provide a
very strong confidentiality protection.